yes Rachel yes me I had such such great
ideas Ean Jean Carol right now is making
the rounds on the media uh and she's
they're loving her because she's talking
sh about big Donald Trump and uh well
here she is on CNN with some of her
plans with that cash you may soon though
have quite a bit of his money and I
wonder how you plan to use that oh it's
inspiring we talk about it a lot we're
going to do do good with that money
we're going to do Mary Trump has
suggested uh we turn Trump Tower into an
animal sanctuary for
instance joke that was a joke poppy uh
no but we're we're inspired to uh do not
waste a penny of this and we have some
good ideas that we're working on
specifically aimed at well what would
oppose Trump well Donald
Trump hates women remember the New York
Magazine the famous quote when when they
said Don what do you think of women he
said
women they're not worth a piece of crap
remember that quote and so I think one
of the things we could do seeing is how
he's very instrumental in taking away
women's rights over their bodies across
the United States maybe we can think
about how we can restore women their
rights use a little of money for that
okay Donald Trump has not taken any way
any woman's rights away right if you're
a woman watching this right now you have
the exact same rights post Donald Trump
that you had pre- Donald Trump we could
talk about abortion and the right to
life and things of that nature but you
get it but the point is they're just
putting her on now she's going on all
the networks just to just like parade
the idea that Donald Trump is just
horrible he hates women we're going to
do all this good stuff with the money
again if she got raped which Donald
Trump was not convicted of would you
would you want to make a show of of all
of this show must go on here's EJ
Carroll on with Rachel mattow serial
liar Rachel matow with she expands on
some of the ideas for the cash you've
talked about using some of Trump's money
that you're about to get um to help
Shore up women's rights do you know what
that might be what that might look like
yes Rachel yes me I have such such great
ideas for all the good I'm going to do
with this money first thing Rachel you
and I are going to go shopping we're
going to get completely new wardrobes
new shoes motorcycle for crawling new
fishing rod for Robbie Rachel what do
you want Penthouse it's yours Rachel
Penthouse and uh France you want France
you want to go fishing in France no oh
all right all right okay that's a
joke although if if me fishing in France
could do something for women's rights I
would take the hit you know I would
obviously take one for the team all
right let me let me
yeah fishing rod for this
one like does this woman seem like she
got raped like wouldn't she be up there
going you know uh Rachel to be clear
this was just on the defamation thing
and not the rape thing and actually I
really I'm going to give all the money
to I don't know women's shelters to stop
rape or like we're going to go shopping
and the the fishing rod did that woman
that woman she strike me as someone that
likes to go fishing but who the hell
knows